hey everyone this is hair thread sterner
sorry and calm and in this video I'm
going to demonstrate how to go up and
down the stairs with a cane so how does
a patient go up and down the stairs with
a cane well the concept is the same like
how we learned with crutches remember I
told you to remember up equals good down
equals bad and what we're referring to
is the good leg going up first which
would be the strong leg versus whenever
we're going down this stairs it would be
the bad leg that's going to go first
so the weak side therefore how do we go
up the stairs using that concept well
what the patient wants to do is they
want to hold the cane on that good slash
strong side then they're going to move
the good leg up onto the step and
they're gonna put weight onto the cane
and then move the cane and the bad leg
up onto the step now to go down the
stairs the patient again is going to
hold the cane on the good side that
strong side they're gonna move the cane
down onto the step with the bad leg so
the bad leg is going down
then they're gonna move the good leg
down onto the step thank you so much for
watching and don't forget to subscribe
to our channel for more videos